we've got a startling admission from the
head of the cdc that the agency has made
serious mistakes during this covet
pandemic which has killed more than a
million americans the u.s has by far the
highest covet death toll in the world dr
rachelle wolinski is now calling for
fundamental change to restore the
public's trust as now monkey pot spreads
and coveted numbers remain high in some
places in the country she spoke to our
doctor john lepuc in an exclusive tv
interview last night
was the agency up to the task of
handling this pandemic i think our
public health infrastructure in the
country was not up to the task of
handling this pandemic dr rochelle
wallensky is vowing to revamp the cdc
after its response to coven 19. we made
some pretty public mistakes and we need
to own them this admission came after
the cdc received the findings of an
external review she ordered of the
agency the cdc says the review found the
agency's coveted guidance was confusing
and overwhelming why did you go ahead
and commission this external review you
know i think it's really important to
understand the great work of this agency
but also to admit to areas where we
needed to improve we owe that to the
american people the cdc says its new
objectives are to share scientific
findings and data faster translate the
science into practical easy to
understand policy and develop what dr
bolinsky called special forces to fight
future pandemics we do now have an
agency that has intense scientific
expertise at almost every area of public
health which is a real gift and what we
really need to do is raise those folks
outside of their silos do you think
they're up to the task of now changing
their whole culture and thinking of
themselves more like special forces that
can be deployed wherever they're needed
i have no doubt that they're up to the
task many say it can't come soon enough
as monkey pox cases spike in the u.s
last week the fda authorized a plan to
stretch out the nation's limited supply
of monkey pox vaccines by offering a way
of administering shots at one-fifth the
dose while eliciting a similar immune
response do you think the criticism that
the cdc has been moving too slowly in
dealing with the monkey pox outbreak
those criticisms are valid we at cdc
still have not seen all the immunization
data that we need to be able to see in
order to mobilize vaccinations across
this country part of those challenges
are similar to some of the challenges
that we had with covet 19 that we don't
have full line of sight and all the data
that we need in order to make real time
decisions dr walensky says it remains a
global fight to get monkey pox under
control we always have the possibility
of reseeding if we don't have it
contained around the world back to the
old statement no one is safe until
everyone is safe for cbs mornings i'm dr
john lepouk